- What's up believe nation.
It's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves.
I want some of that to rub off onto you,
so you can go off and
create something fantastic
and amazing.
Get that thing inside
you out into the world.
And so to help you on your journey,
today we're going to look
at the top five books
or investors.
Coming in at number one is
the Intelligent Investor
by Benjamin Graham.
- It's really a pleasure for
me to be able to talk to you
about Ben Graham.
I've had some lucky days in my life
but one of the luckiest was in
1949 when I was 19 years old
in Lincoln, Nebraska
and I picked up a copy
of The Intelligent Investor.
It not only changed my
investment philosophy.
It really changed my whole life.
I'd be a different person
or in a different place
if I hadn't have foreseen that book.
I got a bedrock of investment philosophies
that really hasn't changed
ever since I read the book.
I may embellish on it a
little here and there.
It was Ben's ideas that
sent me down the right path.
- Coming in at number
two is Rich Dad, Poor Dad
by Robert Kiyosaki.
- Well you have an anniversary as well,
your book turns 20 this year
and has sold over 35 million copies.
So, do the lessons that
you aim to teach I guess
20 years ago, 30 years ago rather, 1997,
do they still resonate today?
- Oh, they're more important
today than ever before
because back in the old days 1997
before you guys were born.
- [Man] Yeah, I wish.
- I said your house is not an asset.
The rich don't work for money
and savers were losers.
And in 2000, everything
started to collapse.
And interest rates dropped below zero,
which has never happened before.
People lost their houses, lost their jobs.
So, it's more important
today than ever before.
And I'm not really saying
if it's right or wrong,
I'm just saying we need
financial education.
What the school teaches about money?
The answers nothing.
- Coming in at number three is Flash Boys,
A Wall Street Revolt by Michael Lewis.
- This week there is a lot of buzz
about a provocative new book focusing
on how it has changed and how
one thousandth of a second
can make a big difference.
The book is titled Flash Boys.
The author is Michael Lewis
who also wrote Money ball,
Liar's Poker and The Big Short.
And Michael Lewis joins us now.
Welcome.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Interviewer] Back to the news hour.
- Yes.
- So, you focus much of the story
on this New York financial trader
who starts out thinking the
markets are all about one thing
and discovers that
there's something wrong.
And basically goes about
trying to change everything.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Why did you focus on him?
- Because I was working on something else.
I needed to learn what
high frequency trading was.
I mean this is a term of art that really
didn't even exist until
three or four years ago.
And it was, my ignorance
was deep on the subject
and I asked big investors
if they could point me
in the direction of someone
who knew about this.
And they said, "There's this
young man, he's Canadian
who's basically running around Wall Street
explaining this to us and he knows more
about these markets than anybody.
And so you got to go see him."
And I went to see him just
really on background to see,
his name is Brad Castillano,
to see what he could teach me about this.
And it turned out that he was
engaged in this essentially
attempt to reform Wall Street from within
to kind of discover what was
wrong with the stock market.
How predictory activity has
arisen in the stock market,
that he had been on the wrong end of.
And then educating American investors
about what was happening.
- Coming in at number
four is Beating the Street
by Peter Lynch.
- [Announcer] In 1900 Peter
Lynch retired as manager
of Fidelity Magellan,
the nation's largest stock mutual fund
and one of the most successful.
In 13 years, he drove
Magellan to a 2800% gain.
Quite simply Lynch has been recognized
as one of the greatest
money managers ever.
He beat the stock market for so long,
not by timing the market but
by picking the right stocks.
Of course, no one can
promise you Peter's record
but you can learn a lot from him
and you don't need a
billion dollar portfolio
to follow his rules.
- Hi my name is Peter Lynch.
For 13 years I managed
Fidelity Magellan fund.
Those were 13 amazing years.
Nine times the market
declined by 10% or more
and I was very consistent.
All of nine times Magellan
fund fell 10% or more.
I learned a lot of lessons.
I think they are true now.
I think they were true 20 years ago.
I think they'll be true 20 years from now.
I think I can help you do
a better job of investing.
- Coming in at number five
is Think and Grow Rich
by Napoleon Hill.
- My search led me the study
of the spiritual forces
with which all of us are blessed.
And it was in this field
that I came upon a clue,
which has enabled me to
help millions of people
to find their earthly destinies.
I want to describe my discovery
in the simplest terms possible
because it will reveal
to you why it is true.
That whatever the mind
can conceive and believe,
the mind can achieve.
Regardless of how many times
you may have failed in the past
or how lofty your aims and hopes may be.
Mr.Carnegy delivered a lecture
that I shall never forget
because it changed my entire life
and paved the way for my
helping to change the lives
of millions of people,
some of them not yet born.
Let me call your attention
to a great power,
which is under your
controls at Mr.Carnegy.
A power which is greater than poverty,
greater than the lack of education,
greater than all of your fears
and superstitions combined.
It is the power to take the
possession of your own mind
and direct it to whatever
ends you may desire.
This profound power Mr.Carnegy
continued is the gift
of the creator and it
must of been considered
the greatest of all of his gifts to man
because it is the only thing over
which man has the complete
and unchallengeable right
of control and direction.
When you speak of your
poverty and lack of education
Mr.Carnegy explained you are
simply directing your mind
power to attract these
undesirable circumstances
because it is true that
whatever your mind feeds upon,
your mind attracts to you.
Now you see why it is
important that you recognize
that all success begins
with definite purpose.
With a clear picture in
your mind of precisely
what you want from life.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoy the video.
I'd love to know how many of these books
have you actually read?
How many are in your library?
Is there a six, seven, eight
that you want to add to the list as well.
But believe nation, other
people watching the video
need to read.
Leave it down in the comments below.
Really curious to hear your thoughts.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is much love.
I'll see you soon.